alors est ce que je vais te manger ce
midi voilà ça a l'air un peu sec
un kilo de carottes inquiets le compte
de terre le compte est bon plus
important pour moi de savoir qui a fait
ces produits qui les a transformés
c'est une histoire des tic au final les
supermarchés ils ont du bon et du
mauvais c'est comme tout et si on sait
faire le tri on peut on peut trouver ce
qui est ce qui est donc on vient aussi
en france je pense qu'on peut tous avoir
les moyens de 2,2 de manger correctement
pour un euro cinquante vous faites un
pot-au-feu par personne et vous avez
l'avion mais vous avez de quoi manger
pendant des jours ma voix compte
c'est sur public sénat
[Musique]